Speaker 1: Fox News reporter John Roberts also
made a fat joke about Chris Christie and then
he ended up apologizing about the joke. Why
don't they ever joke about Trump's weight on
Fox? Trump is obese. Here is the joke. I guess
it's a joke. I don't know from John Roberts.
Speaker 4: To use a modification of a metaphor
that we were using in the panel earlier today.
It's like you have two milkshakes, right? The
Republican Party has two milkshakes and this
one representing almost half the party because
that's what the polling shows, has got one straw
in it. And that's Donald Trump's straw low. Right.
And the other milkshake, which represents the non
Donald Trump part of the Republican Party, has
how many straws in it now? And now we're going
to have Chris Christie straw there. And judging
by Chris Christie's physical stature, he could
drink a lot of that milkshake if he wanted to.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. So, okay, so standard Chris
Christie fat joke. And then John Roberts later
apologizing and saying as soon as it came out
of his mouth, he knew it was a mistake.
Speaker 4: Hey, before we go on, I just
want to take a moment to address something
because I really do feel terrible about it.
Speaker 1: This is now a very
serious and somber John Roberts.
Speaker 4: Earlier on the show, I was making
an analogy to describe the Republican voter
pool. Right. And I made a comment that I meant
to be light hearted but immediately realized
was hurtful toward Governor Chris Christie. I
should not have said what I said. I deeply regret
it and I sincerely apologize to the governor.
Speaker 1: There you go. A very sincere and you
can tell he means it because he used his sincere
anger, man voice, as opposed to the normal voice
that he uses. So, listen, the fat jokes are in
poor taste, but I just want someone to explain
the hypocrisy. Why does Trump get a pass on his
obesity? Trump has been obese for as long as he's
been. In political life. Fox News never brings it
up. Chris Christie announces yesterday and there
are already fat jokes on Fox News. And there's
sort of this irony where John Roberts apologizes
for making a fat joke about Chris Christie when
this has actually been something they've been
doing on the network for a while and Trump has
been doing to Chris Christie for a while as well.
I don't know. I'm curious to hear from folks in
the audience. What is the explanation for this?
Is it that his loyal, loyal followers truly are
the cult members we believe them to be? And so
it doesn't matter. They're sort of blinded by
their cult following of Trump. Is it because
they don't actually even care about obesity?
It's just what can we use as a weapon against
our opponents if our opponents overweight will
use that? But if the guy we like is overweight,
we don't actually care. This is the hypocrisy of
the right wing. This is the nasty scapegoating
nature of the right wing. They can dish it
out. They often can't take it. And of course,
of course, of course, of course they are
hypocrites, period. End of story. All of these
stories will be on our Instagram, which you can
find by searching Instagram for David Pacman Show.